Welcome to the presentation
on multiplying decimals.
Let's get started.
So I think you'll find out that
multiplying decimals is not a
lot more difficult than just
multiplying regular numbers.
And I'll show you in a problem.
Let me pick some
random numbers.
Let's say I had 7,518.
Actually, let's
make that's 75.18.
Clearly you can tell I'm
doing this on the fly.
75.18 times 0.97.
So first you look at this
problem you're like,
oh boy, that's tough.
These decimals-- I don't even
know how to approach it.
Well this is what you do.
You ignore the decimals when
you start the problem and you
pretend like it's just a
regular multiplication problem.
And if you ignore the
decimals like I said, at
the beginning, 7,518 on
top and 97 on the bottom.
And if that doesn't make
sense let me just show you.
I'm just going to ignore the
decimals and do this like a
normal multiplication problem.
So normal multiplication.
I'd start at the 1's
place right here.
I'd say 7 times 8.
Well, 7 times 8 is 56.
Carry the 5.
7 times 1 is 7.
Plus the 5 is 12.
2 down here.
Carry the 1.
7 times 5 is 35.
Plus the 1 is 36.
Put the 6 here.
Carry the 3.
And then 7 times 7 is 49.
Plus 2 is 52.
So just put 52 here.
So just like normal
multiplication we just took the
1's place right here, the 7, so
it's actually not the 1's, but
we're ignoring the decimals so
if there were no decimals this
would be the 1's place.
And we're multiplying
it by the top number.
7 times 7,518 is
equal to 52,626.
And like regular
multiplication, we
do the 10's place.
And this isn't really the 10's
place, but if you ignore
the decimals it would be.
And let's cross all this stuff
out since we're not using it.
9 times 8 is 72.
Carry the 7.
9 times 1 is 9.
Plus 7 is 16.
Carry the 1.
9 times 5 is 45.
This is good practice for
me too, I haven't done
my multiplication
tables in a long time.
9 times 5 is 45.
Plus 1 is 46.
Carry the 4.
9 times 7 is 63.
Plus 4 is 67.
Now we add.
So you're probably thinking,
boy, what do decimals have
to do with this at all.
I'm just doing a regular
multiplication problem.
And I'll show you.
Actually the decimals only come
in right at the very end.
So what I do is now I just add
like I do a regular level
4 multiplication problem.
So I say 6 plus 0 is 6.
2 plus 2 is 4.
6 plus 6 is 12.
Carry the 1.
1 plus 2 plus 6 is 9.
5 plus 7 is 12.
Carry the 1.
1 plus 6 is 7.
OK, so now here's where the
decimals come into play.
And your I think you're
going to be shocked by how
straightforward this is.
What I do is I go back to the
original problem and now I
actually pay attention
to the decimals.
And I say, how many total
numbers are behind
the decimal point?
Well, there's 1 number behind
the decimal point, 2 numbers
behind the decimal point, 3
numbers behind the decimal
point, 4 numbers behind
the decimal point.
1, 2, 3, 4.
So there are 4 numbers behind
the decimal point in the
problem I did, and
I just count here.
1, 2, 3, 4.
The answer will also have 4
numbers behind the decimal
point, and that's the answer.
72.9246.
Now let me ask you a question.
If I had a 0 here, would that
count as an extra number
behind the decimal point?
Well, it only would have been
if you actually used the
0 in the multiplication.
Maybe that confuses you.
What I would recommend if
you have any trailing 0's
with a decimal like this.
you actually should just ignore
those 0's and then do the
problem just the way I did it.
And when remember, that's
only for trailing 0's.
If this was the bottom number
then that 0 would matter
because it's not a trailing 0,
it's actually part
of the number.
Let's do a couple more examples
and I think that'll make sense.
So let's say I had 5-- and
I'm going to do a simpler
example arithmetically.
I think it'll help you
with some principles.
If I said 5.10 times 1.09.
So there's two
things we could do.
We could just multiply
it the way it is.
Actually let's do it both ways
and I'll show you you get the
same answer whether or
not you ignore that 0.
So in the first case
let's not ignore the 0.
Let's use that 0, even though
that trailing 0 in the
decimal-- 5.10 is the
same thing as 5.1.
But let's use it.
9 times 0 is 0.
9 times 1 is 9.
9 times 5 is 45.
And in the 0's place
you put a 0 and then 0
times everything is 0.
0 times 0, 0 times
1, 0 times 5.
Put two 0's here.
And then 1 times 0 is 0.
1 times 1 is 1.
And 1 times 5 is 5.
And now we add it all.
We get 0, 9, 5, 5, 5.
And like we did before, we
just count the decimals.
1, 2, 3, 4.
So 1, 2 3, 4.
So the decimal will go here.
So we got 5.5590 as the answer.
Now what if we did like
I was recommending, we
actually ignored the 0?
And I can actually rewrite
it as 1.09 times 5.1.
Because you know in
multiplication order
doesn't matter.
a times b is the same
thing as b times a.
2 times 3 is the same
thing as 3 times 2.
So 1.09 times 5.1 is the same
thing as 5.1 times 1.09.
So let's just
multiply this out.
And notice, these are
the same numbers.
All I did is I took the 0 off.
So first, I just ignore the
decimals I say 1 times 9 is 9.
1 times 0 is 0.
1 times 1 is 1.
Put a 0 here.
5 times 9 is 45.
Carry the 4.
5 two 0 is 0.
Plus 4 is 4.
5 times 1 is 5.
Now I add.
9, 5, 5, 5.
Now I'm at the point that I
can actually pay attention
to the decimal points.
How many numbers are
behind the decimals?
Well, there's 1, 2, 3.
So I go 1, 2, 3 and put the
decimal point right here.
Notice I got the
same exact answer.
The only difference is that
this one had a trailing 0,
which really doesn't make
a number any different.
I could add a hundred 0's
here and the number's really
not a different number.
If you were a computer
programmer or a statistician
of some kind, this could
be an important number.
But ignore what I just said.
And for your purposes, these
trailing 0's mean nothing.
Same way a leading 0 actually
wouldn't mean nothing.
No one ever does that.
Well, let me see how
much time I have.
I have 2 more minutes.
Let me do one more problem just
to maybe hit the point home.
You know, this is really
no different than level
4 multiplication.
And at the end you just
have to count the numbers
behind the decimal point.
So 5 times 5 is 25.
Whoops.
25.
I'm already getting messy.
Carry the 2.
5 times 7 is 35.
Plus 2 is 37.
Bring down the 7, carry the 3.
5 times 0 is 0.
Plus 3.
So it's 375, ignore that blob.
I'm sorry for being so messy.
And then you put a 0.
1 times 5 is 5.
1 times 7 is 7.
Ignore that.
Now we add.
We say 5 plus 0 is 5.
7 plus 5 is 12.
1 plus 3 plus 7 is 11.
So we got our answer,
now we just have to
count the decimals.
So here we have 1, 2,
3, 4, 5 numbers behind
the decimal point.
But in our answer we only have
4 digits, so how can we get 5
numbers behind the
decimal point?
Well, we start here.
We say 1, 2, 3, 4 and we need
one more number behind the
decimal point, so
we add a 0 here.
And then we put the
decimal point.
See what I just did.
We had to have 5 numbers
behind the decimal point.
And we only had 4
numbers in the answer.
So I added a leading 0 and
then put the decimal point.
And now we have 5 numbers
behind the decimal point.
And I've shown you a very
mechanical way of doing this.
Hopefully in the future I can
give you a seminar on actually
why this method of counting the
numbers behind the decimal
points actually works.
But I think you are ready
to try some problems on
multiplying decimals.
Have fun.